E aí galera que assiste meu canal tudo
bom com vocês Bom eu estou aqui porque
vocês estavam esperando meu
pronunciamento oficial a gente chama de
pronunciamento oficial porque é o
verificado sério o pronunciamento pesado
geralmente é assim que começa o
pronunciamento que ninguém quer saber eu
queria falar aqui uma coisa que até bom
para você mandar para um amigo seu assim
você pegar esse vídeo você mandar para
um amigo seu que você tem muito carinho
que você gosta que você ama muito que
você quer o bem dessa pessoa que são
coisas quando você perceber você vai dar
um salto quântico na sua vida assim você
vai falar Caraca não confunda duas ou
três pessoas falam de você com o mundo
todo a necessidade da gente ser a
atenção todo tempo [__] você sabe o
Instagram sete horas da manhã estava a
pessoa sentado né no story tá toda hora
andando pra lá e para cá você pensa meu
Deus do céu quer falar e não para não
cai na hora do pronunciamento logo se
senta assim pessoal é a respeito do que
tão me perguntando aí do que tão falando
me mencionando aí sempre Então velho
então Ah eu fui pra festa todo mundo
tava dizendo
que o meu seis pessoas de 8 bilhão Ah
mas é porque o Roniel não me quer mais
quem diabo é ruim é o moço e ao mesmo
jeito pro outro lado a todo mundo diz
que gosta de mim
rapaz todo mundo ah todo mundo me ama
rapaz
agora todo mundo
Eu mesmo não pode ser talvez vamos a
circunstância agora Ah não sei o quê
todo mundo me adora não é
que acontece eu sabendo as poucas
pessoas que realmente tem um sentimento
maior por mim eu posso dar mais atenção
aqui realmente gosto de mim de verdade
entendeu sair dessa ilusão de que tá
todo mundo olhando a minha vida não tá e
faz a gente parar de se preocupar com
que a gente não precisa se preocupar e
aí pode gastar energia com outras coisas
porque a gente não tá preocupado que não
tem necessidade de se preocupar eu tô
jogando FIFA mobile eu tô em bermuda
agora é um pouco longe ó
e tem um deckzinho abandonado
ó a casinha
e para chegar até aqui leva um tempinho
né então eu vim jogando de 26 agora tem
o lançamento deve ser mobile com
Vinicius Junior como Embaixador oficial
para você não perder o Hype Você pode
baixar aí o FIFA mobile participar desse
aqui ó que é o evento fundadores E você
já tem o FIFA mobile no seu celular e só
atualizar você não precisa baixar mais
nada é só atualizar de grátis isso aqui
é o botão de fundador se você baixa
mobile você clica no botão de fundador
você pode ganhar Recompensas como emojis
os melhores jogadores Neymar Cristiano
Ronaldo Rala e um bocado mais lá e tem
até o prêmio Star peça para você baixar
para jogar com você lá então o dia 26
agora tem um lançamento tá convide esse
jogo também Embaixador oficial que ele
já tem é só atualizar não tem que baixar
mais nada se você ainda não tem baixa
fica mobile Ou se você quiser fazer
parte da nossa comunidade brasileira não
discord você pode fazer parte então
assim tu tem seu tempo Às vezes a coisa
acontece aí três dias depois ninguém
quer mais saber então nem precisa se
explicar você tem que se explicar para
essas poucas pessoas que aí você
direciona essa energia de mudança na sua
vida para as coisas certas então assim
não perca seu tempo não a vida ela dá
oportunidade de você aprender com os
seus próprios erros todos os dias se
você insiste em fazer de conta que não
entendeu eles vão ficar te procurando a
vida inteira tende logo então faz esse
exercício de trazer esse todo mundo que
existe a tua cabeça para umas sete ou
oito pessoas que é o número mais ou
menos real da coisa para ver se tu não
tá deixando um sonho teu e ir embora
porque tu pensa o que que as pessoas vão
dizer de tu exercendo aquilo rapaz como
é que pode o cara trabalhava no banco
agora diz que quer ser tatuador moço
porque é que não pode de repente você
pode mudar a sua vida a vida da sua
família a vida de uma geração da sua
família foi mais ou menos isso que eu
fiz tentando seguir a carreira artística
na minha família eu não era a pessoa
mais talentosa no mundo não era a pessoa
mais inteligente do mundo não era a
pessoa mais madura do mundo mas eu sabia
que eu conseguiria mudar o quadro caso
eu parasse de ficar ouvindo as pessoas
que estavam me dizendo que eu não
deveria estar fazendo isso porque eu
estava fazendo que me trouxe até onde me
trouxe hoje é por isso que eu quero que
você mande esse vídeo para uma pessoa
que você gosta e se fez sentido para
você eu queria muito que você deixasse
um gostei que isso para mim vale muito
sabe uma coisa que eu fazia Antigamente
eu acho que eu queria que vocês fizessem
de novo que você veio até esse vídeo por
conta de um link no Twitter que eu
postei lá vídeo novo da RT aqui para
fortalecer Então volta lá no Twitch e dá
o RT para poder mandar para mais gente
se você ver essa postagem no Instagram
curte a postagem que você viu isso esse
trecho ou esse print eu não sei o que
que eu postei curte a postagem Marca uma
pessoa que precisa ouvir isso aqui
embaixo pra ele ouvir Como se você
tivesse dizendo assim ê cara eu gosto de
você por causa disso aqui tu não tá
[__] pá que quanto tempo ai foi mal me
diz se concentrei aqui é o mar é muito
bonito aí você acaba danilando gostei aí
cara tu viu que tu gostou tu sentiu uma
parada talvez bacana assim uma coisa que
tu quer dizer até para um amigo teu mas
tu não vai dar no like então dá um like
aí porque eu vou saber se você gostou
porque eu não tenho essa ideia da minha
cabeça que todo mundo gostou desse vídeo
Os é
60 milhão
brincadeira tamo junto até a próxima
fica bem Um grande beijo
beba água Fica tranquilo e sobre o que a
turma tá dizendo por aí né Eu quero
dizer que Quem me conhece sabe